you'll hear a lot about Android devices
but that's just a small part of what
Android really is when you think about a
device like Android and Android device
that's that's a gizmo that's a thing you
can go to the store you can you can buy
that there are ton of devices out there
on the shelf or whatever and you know
maybe someday each one of those would be
running Android you know they all look
different they all it would cost
different
they could be a bunch of different
things they'd all be made by different
people but you know one of our goals
would be to just get Android all over
the place and we've done that in a bunch
of different ways mostly by making it so
that it's really easy for the industry
to adopt we've made it free you don't
have to license it we've done a lot of
work making sure that this platform is
viable to the industry manufacturers and
carriers are more likely to adopt the
whole platform and we make it easy for
developers to extend the platform to
make sure that it stays you know on the
cutting edge of the industry in
developing Android or developing
something like this there's always this
tension between a product and a platform
a platform is what enables you to make
all of those things as we built the
Android platform we've spent a lot of
time thinking about how it's going to be
used in the future there are several
layers in the Android system it's a it's
a complete software stack I've got the
Linux kernel the system libraries Dahl
vaq the application framework and then
all of the applications on top of that
the Linux kernel has been around for
many many years it's tried and true it's
used in millions of computers and
devices but it hasn't really been
thoroughly optimised for for mobile
devices so what we did was we worked on
power management we worked on a new
shared memory driver we worked on this
thing we call the binder which is this
IP lightweight IPC mechanism and we did
work on just on the scheduler to really
make it work efficiently for for a small
device we pulled a lot of libraries in
from the open source community big ones
like WebKit and harmony open SSL the
Apache HTTP components and ICU in
addition to a lot of the other
open-source libraries that Android uses
we're open sourcing a bunch of new
libraries as part of the android
platform among the things that we wrote
ourselves were
a bunch of media codecs so for sound and
video we have graphics libraries 2d and
3d graphics and speech recognition all
Vic is a new virtual machine that was
designed by dan that was intended to be
on these mobile devices it was designed
to deal well in a memory constrained and
CPU constrained environment where you're
operating off of battery power the
application framework makes it easy for
application developers to use all the
different pieces of a mobile device
you're going to have things like the
screen maybe a touch screen a trackball
the buttons a GPS and of course the
platform really wouldn't be complete
without some applications and so we've
built them we've included a web browser
and email client instant messaging
camera for the phone a dialer contacts
and the list goes on at every layer of
the platform we put in hooks to make it
so that people can extend it in ways
that we never even thought of we've
partnered with kernel org to host the
source and we build tools to help
developers interact with the source
we're using git as the source control
system but we build a bunch of tools on
top of it to make it a lot easier to
deal with a platform as large as Android
we have a tool called repo which manages
multiple git repositories and lets
people deal with them as a single unit
this is super important for Android
because in fact we don't have just one
source code repository we have a we have
about a hundred of them we also have a
web-based tool called Gerrit and this is
what we use for source code reviews and
for accepting patches and stuff like
that so if a developer wants to submit a
patch back to the Android source code
they can use Gerrit they can submit
their patch through it and then the
developer who works on that particular
component will be able to see the code
and comment on it and write a review and
there can be kind of back-and-forth
between the main say like the lead for
that component and the person submitting
the patch once the patch looks good you
can just hit the button and it gets
checked in and then it becomes part of
the open source project the Android Open
Source project is ready for you to
explore and contribute right now at its
source android comm what will you do
with android what will you do with
Android